i'm carla hayden the librarian of
congress and i hope you all have been
enjoying yourselves this morning
now
we have
a rather large crowd this morning for
this particular session
and that's why i'm very thrilled to
introduce our next program
for the past year at the library of
congress you may sit down
because i have a few more things
for the past year at the library of
congress we have been celebrating change
makers
and i can think of a few people who more
than aptly fit that description than the
united states supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg
[Applause]
okay i'ma hurry up
she is
a hero and an inspiration to so many of
us in fact at 4 00 a.m this morning
students from american university who
are right over there
camped out in front of this facility
and they are here
she says and i said um justice i you
know we're going to talk about your
graduation from
columbia law school and taught at
rutgers and colombia
spent most of your career advocating on
women's rights and all of these things
and you've been called recently
the beyonce of jewish prudence
and
and the justice i said could i say that
she said i'd rather you say the j-lo
so
without further ado
she is joined
by her co-authors of her best-selling
memoir my own words
co-authors mary hartnett
adjunct professor at georgetown law
wendy w williams a professor of marriage
at georgetown law
and her interviewer today and the
interviewer the person you know very
well from npr miss nina totenberg so
the notorious
r
b
g
[Applause]
please be seated
this way
[Applause]
okay
and i have to tell you before i leave
the stage
i want to shake her hand
[Applause]
well i want to give her a hug but that
would be very unprofessional
so
this is a quite an amazing group and i
i'm
very admiring of all the people who have
been online for
so many hours
and
uh waiting to see the justice
there's a lot to see even though she's a
pretty little person
so
uh
how about jlo what was what how did that
happen
i was called
about a month or so ago
by jennifer lopez
and she said she would like to meet me
and introduce
her fiance alex rodriguez
so they came to chambers so he had a
very nice
visit
she mostly wanted to ask
if i had any secret about a happy
marriage
but now and
a rod is traveling with her
to concerts all over the world
so
uh
what was your secret to a happy marriage
did you pass on your mother-in-law's
secret
and
on the day i was married my
mother-in-law i was married in her home
she took me aside and said
she wanted to tell me
what was the secret of a happy marriage
and i said i'd be glad to hear what is
it
and she responded
it helps sometimes
to be a little deaf
and that good advice i have followed in
every workplace
[Laughter]
including the good job i now have
so if an unkind word a thoughtless word
is said you just tune up
[Applause]
i would personally advise that instead
of chairman mao you listen to justice
ruth
justice ginsburg we all know you've had
some health challenges in the last
year or the last month
you had radiation from most of august
so let me ask you the question that
everyone here wants to ask
which is how are you feeling
why are you here instead of resting up
for the
term and are you planning on staying in
your current job
how am i feeling well first this
audience can see
that i am
alive
and i am on my way to being
very well
[Applause]
and why are you here instead of resting
up for the term
the term we have more than a month
yet to go
and be prepared when the time comes
[Applause]
so how do you just keep trucking
well one thing i love my
job
it's
the best and the hardest job that i have
ever had
and it's what it has kept me going
through four cancer bouts
instead of concentrating on my aches and
pains i just know that i have to read
this set of briefs
go over the
draft opinion
and so i have to
somehow
surmount
whatever my
what's that whatever is going on in my
body
and concentrate on
on the court's work
so uh your book
in my own words
it's the first essentially of two
by
mary hartnett and wendy williams
and you
in some in the first one because it has
a lot of your own words from the time
you were in grammar school and writing
for the school paper and
an opinion opinion pieces and to your
supreme court opinions
um
and then there's going to be a later
authorized
biography these two ladies have been
working on it for some time so mary
hartnett let me let me turn to you for a
moment and ask you
about the upcoming book
i
hesitate to ask this but i'm going to do
it because at least i have four thousand
witnesses
when
can i just say preliminarily that my own
words was to
be second
my official biographers mary and wendy
have been in work how many years 15
years 15 years
2004.
and the idea is the book would come out
the biography would come out and it
would be followed by
selections from speeches i've given
opinions i've written
but the years were
going on and on
and then it came to me that
mary and wendy expected that i would be
on the court for some time
into the future
so they to make the book complete
they wanted to wait
and i said okay let's flip the order
let's have
my selected writings first
and then then the biography
and it was a marvelous idea
[Laughter]
uh so
you still haven't said when so
um that is my job to ask questions you
know this justice keeps doing things and
we're very happy about that
[Applause]
it will be
the idea
originally was that it would break the
story of justice ginsburg it was before
she was notorious but now
[Laughter]
it will be the complete full
story
and so we want to wait
until we have that and hopefully it will
not come out very soon
well done mary
[Applause]
i i talked to you a little bit about the
upcoming book
you won't tell me much but i do know
that there's a whole chapter
about
justice antonin scalia
um
justice ginsburg's great friend um
sparring partner
uh
and entertainer in some ways
so tell me why there is a whole chapter
about him and about your interview of
him sure so there's also a whole chapter
of him about him in my own words
including justice ginsburg's reminisces
about about um
justice scalia
and um and everyone i think in this room
knows about the unlikely
friendship between the two
and interviewing justice scalia was a
real treat for the book and we
interviewed him for the biography but
parts of that interview are in my own
words
and as justice scalia and justice
ginsburg are so different in so many
ways going into his chambers is very
different justice ginsburg's chambers
are light airy modern art
dozens or hundreds of pictures of
friends family colleagues and going into
justice scalia's chamber it's dark
leathery there's a big dead animal
looking down
and so as i sat there interviewing
justice scalia
i watched how he went from the kind of
tough jurist that we all know and his
face just softened and lightened up as
he talked about his good friend ruth
and
he he told several stories one
was when they traveled to india together
and they went to visit the taj mahal
and justice scalia described how he
watched justice ginsburg
listen to the tour guide describe the
love story behind the building of the
taj mahal
and he said he saw tears start to stream
from her eyes and as he told me that i
98 sure it's that i saw a tear not
related to an opinion or a descent come
out of it
and the other story that um
he liked to talk about
was a parasailing
justice ginsburg at
when she was a young 70 year old
was in niece for a illegal exchange
and was standing in the hotel looking
out at the water and saw all these
people parasailing and she turned to her
husband marty and said
marty that looks like fun we should do
that
marty looked horrified and said
are you crazy and if you do that i'll
remember you to our grandchildren
the dean who was the host said
i'll go parasailing with you this was
dean yellen
and
his wife was equally horrified and she
said if there's an accident and they can
only save one of you it better not be
you
but
so to
so they went parasailing they had to
adjust for weight because dean yellen
was a normal sized human being and there
was justice ginsburg and off they went
and they went up and down and up and
down plopped into the water and
wendy and i asked justice ginsburg about
this experience a few years ago
when we were interviewing her and said
what was it like did you like it and
justice ginsburg said it was
marvelous glorious and then she related
it of course to a greek myth
and said it was like icarus but we
didn't
get too close to the sun
the weight was also a problem
in rajasthan
when we took a ride on a very elegant
elephant
there was a photograph of it
my feminist friends asked why are you
sitting in the back of the elephant
[Laughter]
and i explained it had to do with the
distribution
justice ginsburg you've always been a
rather determined person
when you were in law school your husband
was diagnosed with
testicular cancer
doctors told you his chances of survival
were extremely slim
but the two of you just carried on
and as we all know he survived
but i thought people here might be
interested
in what your days and nights were like
in that year
and how how in some ways it set up your
sleep patterns for life
it was my second year in law school
marty's
third year
and there was massive surgery
followed by massive radiation
there was no chemotherapy
in in those days
we just took each day as it came
my routine was
i would attend my classes
i had no takers
in order marty's classes
i would then go to
mass general the hospital where he was
in the afternoon
and then when he was released from the
hospital
and was having daily radiation
he was first very sick
and then he would sleep
until about midnight
when whatever food he
ingested that day
he would have
my
not very good
cooking
[Laughter]
and then about two o'clock in the
morning oh he was also dictating his
senior paper to me
he went back to bed about two in the
morning and that's when i hit the books
myself
and in between there was our then
two and a half year old
daughter
so i
for weeks many weeks i was sleeping
maybe two hours
a night
and that's how i became
a night person
i appreciated that in those early
morning hours the telephone didn't ring
there were no emails in those days
it was a quiet time i could concentrate
on on the books
well i hope you're getting more than two
hours these days
i do know that if you want to
call the ginsburg residence
you do not
on a non
on a day
like a weekend day you do not call
before noon
but that's not true on sitting days not
not true not through on court days at
all
so today
women to some extent
take for granted their
equality in the workplace
but that was not the case when you were
a young lawyer
you couldn't get a job in a law firm
you had not one but two strikes against
you you were
well i was
first a jew and there were many three
strikes
long
well known firms in new york that were
not yet up to welcoming jews
the next i was a woman
that was a higher barrier
but the absolute killer was i had a
four-year-old daughter when i graduated
from law school
you were a mother so if they would take
a chance on a woman
a mother was more than they were willing
to risk
so
you had top grades at harvard and in
your last year of law school when you
moved to new york with your husband you
were tied for first place at columbia
law school
and you're applying for clerkships
and
tell us
how you finally did get a clerkship
because nobody by and large would even
interview you for the most part
yes those were pre-title seven days
so employers were upfront about
saying
women are not welcome at this workplace
or
we had a lady lawyer once and she was
dreadful
so how many men have you had that didn't
work
but i had a wonderful professor at
columbia law school who later moved
to stanford jerry gunther
he was in charge of getting clerkships
for columbia students
and he called
every
federal judge
in the second circuit
in the southern east eastern districts
of new york
and he was not meeting with
success
so he called a columbia graduate judge
edmund palmieri
who was a columbia undergraduate
columbia law school graduate and always
took his clerks from columbus columbia
and he said
i strongly recommend
that you engage ruth bader ginsburg
and palmieri's response was
i've had women law clerks i know they're
okay
but she's a mother
and sometimes we have to work on
weekends
even on a sunday
so professor gunther said
give her a chance and if she doesn't
work out
a young man in her class
who's going to a downtown firm
will jump in and take over
so that was the carrot
it was also a stick
and the stick was
if you don't give her a chance
i will never recommend another colombian
columbia graduate as your law clerk
that's the way
it was in
not so ancient days
for women
the big hurdle was to get that first job
once
a woman
got the job she did it at least as well
as the men
so the second
job was not
the same obstacle
there's a wonderful book this is a
meeting about books so let me mention it
is called first
and it's about
it's the biography of sandra day
o'connor
she was very high in her class at
stanford law school
but
no
law firm would
hire her she was asked do you type
and maybe there would be a place
as a legal secretary
so what did she do
she went to a county attorney and said i
will work for you without pay
for four months
and then if you think i'm worth it
you can put me on the payroll
that's how
sandra darrell kind of got her first job
but even after your clerkship you
couldn't get a job in a law firm you
ended up
being a law professor no i i could have
gotten a job in fact i was going to a
firm
when a professor another professor from
columbia han smith
said
how would you like to write a book about
the
swedish judicial system
well this is a part of her life you will
not hear generally discussed so you're
in on
a question
that
normally doesn't come up
how is your swedish by the way into so
far
anyway
this was
an irresistible offer because
here i was in my 20s
before i turned 30 i would have a book
between hard covers
marty and i married the same month i
graduated from cornell so i had never
lived on my own i went from a college
dormitory to being married
and i had what might be called the eight
year itch
i wanted to see if i could manage on my
own and the deal was i would go to
sweden
my daughter jane would be taken care of
by her father
for about six weeks and when she
finished school
she came and joined me in sweden
and i got that out of my system
i never again
yearned to
live on my own
oh when it was the opportunity to learn
about a culture
and to learn a language that i knew
nothing at all
about
so you
wendy one of you did you go back to did
you go to sweden with her you mary you
went to she went back to sweden this
year yesterday
it was it was the 50th anniversary of my
honorary degree from the university of
london
and and you saw there
what did you see on the streets
your picture
yes
there were posters up and down the
streets of one of the
many many events that the justice did in
sweden she was very over programmed for
three or four events a day but she
wasn't daunted but we kept trying to see
the poster as the car was zooming
through the streets and it was
like that scene in the movie um
french kiss where they never see the
eiffel tower we kept looking and looking
and finally driving to the airport
remember we turned and there it was
wendy
you've been working on this book for 15
years with mary
did you interview all of the justices
she served with
how often did you interview her
what do you do
when
you have 15
plus
years what is your agenda
when you before you answered let me tell
you how all this began
so
you're not going to get wendy and mary
came to see me and they said
inevitably people are going to write
about your life
so
why don't you
make as your official biographers people
you really trust
and i certainly trusted wendy and i were
in the trenches in the 70s
when for the first time in history
it became possible
for courts to accept that the equal
protection clause
meant that women were people equal in
stature to many
[Applause]
so
i
knew
[Music]
wendy's strategy and mine were pretty
much the same and knew that she
understood what we were trying to
accomplish so i said yes without
hesitation
in fact when we
when we came to her to talk about it she
sat us down at a little table and on the
table there was a stack of documents and
opinions and other things about this
high
and she said oh here's a little
something that you might want to look at
that
that's how we knew we were
in so to speak
so did you in fact interview all of the
justices she served with
i did not interview
any of the justices she served with but
mary did
yeah i mean did the two so the every
between the two of you you interviewed
them all
we did yeah actually not all of them but
some refused to be interviewed well and
and there are some
newer editions who will still play we
still plan to interview but
but most of them and how often
did you sit down with her for an
extended interview i'm assuming it's a
lot it's a lot
we started out
in that little
moment in time
after she was
done with her summer and just before she
had to knuckle down
and prepare for the coming term and
every year in august
most often in the last week
we
we sit down with her for three
days in a row
in the late afternoon so we have
we have our own big stack from that
and she and this year it was a little
different
we um we went up to new york where she
was getting her
radiation treatment and uh it was
amazing how could she
anyway so we sat with her twice up there
and she um
she remembered everything she was
perfectly normal except she was very
tired which she has never let stop her
and she wasn't
letting it stop her then
and that was and that was uh that was a
new experience for us in new york but
then we came back down for one day day
before yesterday and did our
third third day so every year we do that
and then we do a lot of things in
between to keep track of her
so let me just say this to you too
here in front of god and everybody
justice brennan famously had an
authorized biographer who got writer's
block after he died
and and somebody else eventually had to
take over the project yes
and i'm getting old is that what you're
saying
i'm saying to you you better not get
writers
we all want to see that
everybody here some of whom are a great
deal younger than me want to be able to
read the product of your labors
well we do too so
the deal
you know i'm taking for granted this is
a very
educated and
curious audience i'm taking for granted
that everybody in this room has seen rbg
at least once
and
and on and on the basis and on the basis
of sex so i'm not going to go through
all of the
cases and the strategy and all of that
of justice ginsburg because there are
other places where you've
seen this but there are also a lot of
young people in this audience
um men and women
and i wanted to ask justice ginsburg
in light of that and in light of all of
the conversation that we have these days
about balance between
work and family life to tell us the
story of the elevator thief
[Laughter]
the elevated thief
was my
lively son
it was when he was in the sixth grade
i called him lively
his teachers called him hyperactive
and i would get calls about once every
month to come down to the school
to talk about
my son's latest escapade
but one day i was sitting in my office
at columbia law school
the phone rang
it was the headmaster
we need to see you immediately
i've been particularly weary that day
because i had stayed up all night
writing a
brief so i said
this child has
two parents
please alternate calls and it's his
father
[Applause]
so they called marty who was then the
head of the tax department and a large
law firm
he came down
and was told your son
stole the elevator
[Laughter]
and marty's immediate response was
he stole the elevator
how far could he take it
so i don't know if it was marty's sense
of humor
by the way the the theft was it was one
of those
old-fashioned handheld elevators
the operator went out
for a smoke
one of james's classmates
challenged him to take the kindergarten
class up to the top law
which he did
so after that episode
the calls came barely once a semester
there was no quick change in my son's
behavior
but
the school was much more reluctant to
take a father away from his word
than a mother
so the suggestion to alternate
calls
did the trick
so
i want to um
let me just add that that son is today
a fine human
and
he's not in prison anywhere and he's a
great parent to
two to two girls and because she won't
do it i will he has he runs a thing
called sadia records c-e-d-i-l-l-e
and it they produce magnificent
classical recordings okay that's my
you that would be inappropriate for you
to do but not me
so let's talk about your time on the
supreme court
you're appointed by president clinton
and within three years
of
getting to the supreme court you're
still a very junior justice
you're assigned to
write the
virginia terror virginia military
institute case
striking down their policy of exclusion
of women
um
and
you you would not have gotten that just
that assignment
but for your female colleague justice
o'connor right
yes
and the seniority is
a very big in a workplace so
justice o'connor would have been
way ahead of me
as a
chosen opinion writer
but sandra said
ruth should write this opinion so it's
thanks to justice o'connor that i got to
write
the decision in the virginia military
institute case
so
you wrote in that case that
most
most women indeed most men would
probably not
want to meet the demands the rigorous
demands of vmi
but those extraordinary individuals who
can meet those demands and want to meet
those demands should be permitted to
so you were invited to vmi
a little over a year ago i think
[Music]
to give a speech
how did that go
in fact they had invited me to come to
bmi at the
20th anniversary of the decision
my calendar was too crowded so it turned
out to be the 21st
anniversary
and you were with me yes for that
the the change in that
that school has been
enormous
the
commanding officer was so proud of his
women cadets
they live in the same
spot and quarters that the men live in
but they were so enthusiastic
many of them were in the engineering
program one wanted to be an atomic
scientist
for the school
by admitting women they were able to
upgrade their applicant pool
considerably
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wendy where did she leave out
well she left out um
a ginsburg scalia moment
um
to begin with
because when justice scalia found her
opinion fairly outrageous and and he was
very upset about
the whole thing
and his last sentence of his opinion
said something like
um
[Music]
this this this is going to destroy
vmi he used the word destroy
and um i asked
justice ginsberg about that later and
she said to me with perfect this was
this was not so long after the opinion i
think
she said to me with
the utmost confidence
vmi will be a better place if they're
women
and it won't be destroyed
and the wonderful thing about that was
when we were there
for the 24th first anniversary
people there were so proud and excited
to have you in person come there after
you had transfigured the place that
there was an audience almost as big as
this
and
back there there were
what do you call them
bleachers bleachers bleachers and all
the cadets were there in their uniforms
and
for ruth ginsburg they all stood up
and applauded it was just remarkable
and as it turned out
justice scalia was the sole
dissenter yes in the vmi case
the then chief chief justice rehnquist
didn't join my opinion but he did join
the judgment
justice thomas was accused because his
son
attended vmi he couldn't park just so
that left scalia all alone
[Laughter]
justice scalia knew i felt deeply about
the case as he did the other way
and he came to my chambers one day
threw down a sheaf of papers and said
ruth this is the pen ultimate draft of
my
descent in the vmi case
i'm not yet ready to circulate to the
court
but the clock was ticking
and he wanted to give me
as much time as he could
to
answer his
rather strident dissent
you were going to the uh
second circuit meeting
yes i was going to the judicial
conference in lake george i was on the
plane
opened up his descent
it absolutely ruined my weekend
[Laughter]
but i was certainly glad to have the
extra time
to respond
so
talking about vmi reminds me that when
you get to the court
justice o'connor of course was the first
woman justice she's there she's been
there for quite a while 12 years by
herself
and as you would later learn that's no
fun because you got to be the only one
for a while too
and you know she was a reagan appointee
she was a girl of the west
you were
a clinton appointee
you were from new york city
and i wondered
and you you very quickly though
established a very special bond
she was as close as i came
to having
a big sister
when i came on board she gave me some
advice not too much he didn't want
to douse me with
with excessive information just what i
needed to know
to navigate
those first few weeks
and then she was an enormous help
in my first cancer about justice
o'connor had a mastectomy
and was on the bench
nine days after her surgery
so she was going to tell me how to
manage this
she said you schedule chemotherapy for a
friday
that way you can get over it
during the weekend and be back in court
on monday
and she also said you're going to get
in those days that were not yet emails
but
you're going to get calls you're going
to get letters
from all over
don't even try to respond
just concentrate
on getting the court's work done
i'm not telling any secrets here when i
say that in
in
many of the court's biggest cases of
late
you are not all but you are in the
minority on the dissenting side
but you know in the last
five years or more
you have pulled out some unexpected
victories
and i'm thinking for instance of the
court's
2015 decision upholding arizona's
redistricting commissions these were
created by state
referenda
by the voters
to limit partisanship in the drawing of
legislative districts in the state
and
will you tell the audience what your
opinion said
but then that the opinion said the
opinion said you you upheld them why
because something needs to be done
about the partisan
gerrymander
and
i think
california was in the lead
in arizona the good voters of arizona
were
tired of drawing district lines when
there was very little incentive to vote
because your district had been rigged it
was going to be a republican seat or
democratic seat
so your vote didn't count that's not the
way a democracy should run
so
arizona
and california had the idea and this was
not done by their state legislatures
state legislatures would not willingly
give up
the monopoly they had on redistricting
so the
good people of the state said this
should be done the redistricting should
be done by an independent
commission
not by
partisan members of the legislature
he presented a constitutional question
because the constitution says
redistricting will be done by the
legislature thereof
so some of my colleagues said
legislature means legislature and it
doesn't mean
the people
to me it seemed
quite clear that the state had made
the people
the legislature for this purpose
states that have referendum
do that
they give the deciding voice to to the
people
to we the people
and not the partisan members of the
legislature and i think that after
that case
other states were encouraged other
states that had
a referendum
so the dissent in that case was written
by chief justice roberts and he
argued very vigorously
that the legislature means only the
legislature now fast forward to this
year
a five to four conservative majority
ruled
essentially that the voters have no
ability to challenge extreme partisan
gerrymanders in court
but at the same time
the opinion written this time majority
opinion written by the chief justice
seem to suggest that other remedies like
independent redistricting commissions
provide alternative ways to address the
problem of partisanship in redistricting
so
could you please explain what's going on
here
have the court's conservatives change
their minds about redistricting is this
just window dressing or what
as one lives one learns so i think the
chief learned that he was wrong in the
area
[Applause]
so um
i want you to look at this crowd
they tell me this is 4 thousand people
i'm not quite sure
next week you and i are going to
another interview
in little rock arkansas
in a venue that holds
18 000 people
and not only are all the tickets gone
there's a waiting list of
16 000 people
[Applause]
so
so my dear notorious rbg
how does it feel
to be a cultural and pop icon in your
80s
[Applause]
it's amazing that
at the advanced age of 86
everyone wants to take a picture with me
the notorious
rpg was started by a second year student
at new york university law school
she was
dismayed about the decision the court
had recently rendered
in the shelby county case
that held the key provision of the
voting rights act
of 1965 unconstitutional
then she thought to herself
i'm angry about that
but anger will not
get me any place
so i'm going to do something positive
the positive thing that she did
was she put on the internet in a tumblr
and
the
announcement i made from the bench of my
dissenting opinion
in the shelby county case
and she called it
the notorious rbg because
she had in mind a well-known rapper
the notorious b.i.g
and people ask me
what in the world do you have in common
with the notorious yeah
i said it's evident
[Applause]
and we were both born and bred in
brooklyn new york
[Applause]
by the way when you and justice o'connor
were on the court
even at the end
of
her tenure
some very seasoned
supreme court advocates not newbies
really seasoned people kept confusing
you
and they would call you justice o'connor
and her justice ginsburg and excuse me
you don't look anything alike
she had at least six inches on you
her hairstyle was different
her accent was there everything was
different
why
for 12 years
sandra day o'connor was the lone woman
on the supreme court
and advocates were accustomed to there
being a woman on the court her name was
sandra day o'connor
so they heard a woman's voice
it had to be
justice o'connor
[Laughter]
that she would sometimes say
i am justice o'connor she's justice
ginsburg
that happened
not to just occasional
lawyers who showed up but even
the solicitor general
mortified as soon as he
he called me justice o'connor and
realized
the mistake that he had made
he said he wanted he had a was wish that
there was a trap door under his feet
but nowadays
we are one third of the bench
[Applause]
and we are all over the bench because of
my seniority i sit next to the chief
with justice sotomayor on one side
justice kagan on the other
people who have attended argument
at the court
know that my
my
two sisters-in-law
are not shrinking violence
they're very active in the columbus
that goes on in fact i think for some
years there was a rivalry
between justice scalia and justice
sotomayor who could ask the most
questions
sometimes she won
so it seems to me appropriate since we
began this interview um
talking about justice scoulier we should
end it in some ways there because the
two of you were such pals for so many
decades and such unlikely
that was such an unlikely friendship to
people from the outside why were you
what did you what did you love about him
so much
he was a very funny man
you know he had been buddies on the d.c
circuit
for some years before he was appointed
to the supreme court and that that was a
three-judge bench
sometimes he would whisper something to
me
that was
so funny i had everything
i could do to contain myself from
bursting out into hysterical
laughter
and in the supreme court when we didn't
sit next to each other
he would sometimes send me
notes
i can't repeat this audience what some
of them were
and
there's
there's a comic opera called scalia
ginsburg
that characterizes
the two of us
the different way we approach reading
legal text
but our reverence for the court as an
institution
and for our constitution
so
db was just a small sample of
this very amusing opera
scalia's opening aria is
a rage arya it's very handly in its
style and it goes like this
the justices are blind
how can they possibly spout this
the constitution says
absolutely nothing
about this
and then i answer him
dear justice scalia you are searching
for brightline solutions
to problems that don't have easy answers
but
the great thing about our constitution
is that like our society
it can
evolve
[Applause]
so the plot is roughly based on the
magic flute justice scalia is locked up
in a dark room
he is being punished for excessive
dissenting
[Laughter]
and i enter the dark room through a
glass ceiling
[Applause]
and say i'm there to help him pass the
tests he needs to pass to get out of the
dark room
and a character called the commentatory
said
why would you want to help him
he's your enemy
and i explained
he's not my
enemy
he's my dear friend
and then we
sing a wonderful duet
it goes like this
we are different
we are one
different in our approach to legal texts
but one
in our reverence for the institution we
serve
and for the united states constitution
[Applause]
so
i know this seems like a very short time
but we have already exceeded it
and i thank
the justice
her biographers
all the people
here who
waited so long to come
this has been a lovely morning
thank you justice ginsburg
thank you
thank you very much everyone please
please be seated thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]